Yuri and Alex Pier Chen who you got on
this I'm going for yui I want him to win
I just like him a lot but you don't like
Alex he's awesome too but I'm just
saying like Yuri's like the more the
personality that I I like Anyway
watching Yuri's fights he gets tagged a
lot dude his Chin's really great but
against Alex nuclear Brazilian bombs
it's so accurate too Alex is so accurate
so if I had a pick I think Alex takes it
me too yeah yeah I'm with you Yuri does
get hit a lot he had the win over Glover
uh in the fifth round the Dominic rays
and he's coming off an injury hasn't
fought in a hot second either and it was
like one of the worst shoulder injuries
what they say yeah I'm curious how he
comes back after that all signs would
Point towards Alex Alex wins this he was
a champion at middleweight champion at
light heavyweight he's beat the current
champion at middleweight and Sean
Strickland but he has to be the only guy
with 11 fights that gets into the UFC
Hall of Fame first ballot insane how
fast he's got it done